And everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and we're ready for another holistic health
hour.
We've got a bunch of questions that came in.
Reminder for you, who don't know, or this is the first time you've seen us, go to holistichealthour.com,
where you could ask your questions.
You could also do it on the live chat, connect the chat right now.
So we're ready to go.
So if you have questions, feel free to chat them in, otherwise go to holistichealthour.com,
and you could post your questions out of there, and like a bunch of people did, then I'm
going to answer, or at least make it a tip to answer.
Right now, first question came in.
Do you have any suggestions for a foot bath detox unit that has no or low EMFs?
I've used some in the past they've had higher EMFs, so they've had problems.
Well, I don't know if you have an EMF meter that you're measuring, those EMFs, or you've
just had issues of ill health, when you've used it, I don't know.
We don't sell a foot bath detox unit to our patients.
Most of our patients have a true right unit.
And the true right unit comes with an ion pro wave.
And we have tested that with a EMF meter, and it is very low EMF, there's no EMFs coming
out of that.
You can get some EMFs coming out of the computer because it's a computer-based program.
So when you hit run on the program, whether you're using the true right with the bulb, or whether
you're using the true right with the ion pro wave, the EMFs are mainly coming out of
the computer.
That's why we always suggest people to close their computer and put it to sleep, and then
they don't get any EMFs.
As a standalone foot bath unit, the standalone units that are out there, I know Ercolia makes
a good one.
Ion cleanse was the original, and they probably make the best one that's out there on the market.
There's a lot of standalone foot bath detox units that are out of China that I would not recommend.
I've tested a few of those, and I don't think they work very well at all, and I've had people
give me theirs to try on, and I still think they work very well at all.
So I wouldn't suggest those, I know they're a far cheaper.
But I do not know that Ion cleanse nor do I know if the Ercolia brand, what the EMF output
on those is.
I've never tested that, so I can't testify to that.
Next question, can a nine-year-old with type 1 diabetes use a rife machine to heal?
Well, can a nine-year-old use a rife machine?
So it turns out what type of rife machine you're talking about, so there's a lot of machines
on the market that say that they're a rife machine, because there's no legalities about calling
your apparatus a rife machine.
Rife is just the last name of royal raiment rife, who came up and really put frequency
healing on the map.
So there's a lot of machines out there that are rife machines.
We advocate to use the true rife brand rife machine, but I also think the GB4000 rife machine
is a good rife machine.
Can a nine-year-old use those machines?
The answer is yes, there really are no contra-indications.
The GB4000 can be its own radio frequency background, that's what it's using to push it.
There can be some contra-indications to that.
With the true rife brand, there's no contra-indications.
It is a true high-frequency machine that's using light frequencies.
There's no contra-indications for age.
You can use it pregnant women, can use it little babies, can use it.
People with implanted devices can use it.
There's no negatives to using it.
There's no as far as electrical devices, nothing like that.
Is it going to be a good fit to use for type 1 diabetes?
I don't know.
Can you run?
So type 1 diabetes is an autoimmune attack, destruction of the cells in the pancreas that make insulin.
So is the rife machine going to heal that?
I don't think so.
If I had a nine-year-old that had type 1 diabetes, would I try using the rife machine?
Sure, absolutely.
Can light frequencies be amazing and heal things that you never would have thought that that would heal?
Yes, but we have to use wisdom too.
Is it the best tool for the job?
Well, there really isn't any tools that are going to heal an autoimmune disease.
You have to, as far as like therapy goes, whether it's rife or whether it's laser or whether
it's ultrasound or electrical stem or anything like that, there isn't going to be a tool that's
going to heal type 1 diabetes.
You have to deal with diet issues, you have to look for triggers.
I have a whole course on autoimmune diseases, but definitely with type 1 diabetes, you have
to control blood sugar levels, you know, that could be deadly.
So if you're not under medical care to control those blood sugar levels as well.
But would it be something that you certainly could try?
Certainly, absolutely.
Would it be something that I would say that would be my first choice that I think this is
going to heal it?
I don't think so.
But just try to be honest, you know, it's just rife and other therapies and other nutritional
products, except they're just tools.
So after we properly applied, just like, okay, I have a screw to screw in, should I use
a hammer?
Well, you could do the job with a hammer.
Is it the right tool to use?
No.
You know, you have to kind of board and have to use a hammer?
No, it's totally not the right tool for the job.
You know, suppose you could break the mornin pieces, but you're certainly not doing a very
good job of it.
It's not the right tool for the job.
Same thing with the rife machine.
The rife machine can heal yourselves.
Could it be possible that it could heal yourselves?
Now, somebody might be listening to this and they say they might call it and say I used
the rife machine to heal my type 1 diabetes with those child.
So I'm not saying that it can't happen, but I wouldn't be necessarily my first choice
of that tool.
Next question, soy mimics estrogen.
So if I don't have cancer, would eating organic fermented soy help increase my estrogen levels?
My postmanopausal and my Dutch test confirm that estrogen is very low.
Thank you.
Okay.
So, soy, if your estrogen levels are really low, would you eat soy to bring your estrogen
levels up a little bit?
Well, I would eat soy isoflaminoids.
It's a constituent of soy, but it's not just eating like tofu.
Or soy product.
So it's going to have the benefits of helping balance your estrogens, but it's not going
to like spike your estrogens, it's not going to give you the negative zero estrogens that
could cause issues in your body.
Fermented soy is the chimna.
Fermented soy works differently in your body than soy.
There are some studies that fermented soy actually can decrease your estrogen load.
So if you're trying to increase your estrogens, I guess fermented soy wouldn't be the choice.
Now, understand the benefit of fermented soy really lies with people that have cancer,
especially estrogen receptor positive cancer.
Because fermented soy has been shown to dislodge those bad estrogens from the receptor sites,
from the beta estrogen receptor sites on the cancer cells, which when bad estrogens attach
to that beta estrogen site, it actually blocks extrinsic apoptosis.
And fermented soy has been shown to dislodge that.
Now, regular soy increases your estrogen load, which can then degrade into the 4-hydroxy
esterone, which can be that bad estrogen that attaches to that estrogen beta receptor.
So there's a very difference if a person has cancer, and especially if they have estrogen
or progesterone or her too positive cancer, they don't want to be eating soy.
But fermented soy, they do want to eat because it can actually work the opposite of soy.
It dislodges that bad estrogen from that receptor site, allowing a greater degree of apoptosis
to take place.
So it stands to reason at least, I believe that fermented soy is not going to increase your
estrogen levels.
So I don't think to answer that question, I don't think fermented soy would be the choice.
I would use soy, soy, but I would say you have to get that supplement form.
When it comes to food allergies, IgG, in particularly, being they can change so frequently, how often
would you recommend testing?
I feel like it shows the state of your gut at that moment, but can change often.
Well, I agree for a large part, IgG, IgA, food allergies, food sensitivity testing can be
a little fickle, but that gives us a good picture of what could be causing inflammation at that
time.
Now, it depends on the food itself.
Some studies haven't done with gliadid IgG antibodies.
It shows that they could last forever and cause problems forever, even if the person is on a
complete, very strict gluten-free diet, but then other foods can dissipate quite quickly.
So when we do like a Cyrex 10, which tests for IgG antibodies, and separates cooked from raw
foods, which I think gets more specificity in your testing, I recommend testing retested
at three months, if that's the person's made concern that we're dealing with trying to
call no, the inflammation of the gut.
Again, when you do a food sensitivity test, it's not so much, I'm looking for what I can eat
and can't eat, yes, there's that piece of that, okay, I have high antibodies to whatever,
so I'm going to keep that out of my diet, but it's giving you an indication of the amount
of inflammation that's in your gut.
If you come back with a food sensitivity test and you have so many things in the yellow and
red, I mean, it's high antibodies to soak to a lot of different things, it really tells
that there tells you that there's a lot of inflammation that's going on in your.
You do want to investigate whether you have parasalular or transalular forms of leaky gut,
differentiates between that and you do want to differentiate whether you have antibodies
to lipopolysaccharides as well, because that's going to tell you other indications of the severity
of the gut permeability that's going on, so a Syrex array 2 could be beneficial to tell you those
things, that tells you the severity that you need to really deal with this issue too.
So, again, if you're doing a food sensitivity test and all you're doing with that data is changing
your diet, you're really missing the whole point. You're doing a food sensitivity test to change the
diet but then to decrease the inflammation and to start healing the gut, so you have to be working on
things that are going to heal your gut along with that, or all you're going to do is you're going to do
another test in three months and you're going to have different things that are going to be out of balance.
Oh, now it's not this, but it's this that was in the green before. How come
what's the deal? Do you ever think that anything to actually fix the problem?
With most leaky gut issues, I think I've described this before in other holistic health hours you
could have, would you describe most leaky gut issues? It's typically been described
when the gut cells separate from one another and you don't have those tight junctions. That's
called pericelular permeability. It can get worse than that. You could actually have transcellular
permeability where the the cells themselves are so damaged that things are going through the cells
and then it tested if you have antibodies to lipopolysaccharides that gives you other clues. Do you
know that you have a grand negative bacteria issues as well? Because if you have antibodies to
lipopolysaccharides, then you already know that you have damage to the blood brain barrier as well.
So healing those barriers is a key to the really getting better.
Greetings from Northern California. Oh, hello, Northern California.
Our blood cancers such as chronic lymphoma, estrogen driven. No. So the blood cancers are not
going to be estrogen driven cancer. So the estrogen driven cancers are going to be breast cancer,
uterine cancer, ovarian cancer, things like that that are going to be estrogen driven. That's the
cancers that are be tested for ERPR, HER2 positive or negative. So you won't have to worry about
that. I mean, so should somebody not worry about their estrogen? I wouldn't say that. You still
should not ignore the Zenoestrogens because they cause other damages too. So does everybody need to
do a hormone test? No, but there is benefits to doing a Dutch test, especially for a female,
because we're so exposed to somebody's Zenoestrogens understand the definitions. Zenoestrogens
are the estrogens that you get from your from the environment in estrogen disruptors that affect
your hormone balance from the environment. So whether you have cancer or not or whether you have an
estrogen or progesterone or HER2 positive or negative cancer, there can be great benefit to looking at
your estrogen progesterone, energy and levels. And a good way to do that is through what's called
a Dutch test. It's a dry, teary test. Easy to get. You can order it on our site and you do it at
home and set it into the lab. It gives you a lot of data for the money to really see what's going
on. It is interesting because you'll see people that are like might be off the board with
some certain hormones that it can then when you do, when you start to read up on it, it can lead
to a lot of other symptoms you're having. And understand, first of all, let's say I have lymphoma,
well, it has nothing to do with estrogen, but it can lead to a lot of other comorbidities and
ability for my immune system to function and to be able to fight off other diseases, including
cancer. So would you do Dutch test on women on birth control or homework replacement therapies?
If so, aren't those numbers quite skewed? Yes, they can be. So there's some requirements when
you do a Dutch test, you have to put in if you're on any of those hormones. But if you're doing
hormone replacement therapy, you do want to do hormone testing because how do you know you're doing
the right level of dosage of replacement? So hopefully the doctor who is prescribing hormone
replacement therapies is doing hormone testing. Otherwise, they're just guessing. So they should be,
they should be doing that. If you're on birth control, yes, there are stipulations in the Dutch test
and they'll ask you those kind of questions. And depending on where you have to be in the cycle,
even if you're not on any birth control, you have to take the test, depending if you're still
then a pre-medipausal ux takes test to certain times of your cycle. Okay, next question. What are your
thoughts about taking methylene blue, resembling with chronic Lyme and co-infections and brain fog?
Yeah, that's not contraindicated for Lyme disease. You can certainly take that.
If a person has a chronic Lyme or chronic an autoimmune disease, if you're going to be adding
supplements, my recommendation is to add them one at a time. Because sometimes, if you look at my
autoimmune course, you'll see that you don't want to be taking things. If you have an autoimmune disease,
you don't want to be taking things that are immune stimulators because you already have antibodies to
self-tissue. But if you're going to take things that are immune stimulators, well, you're basically
stimulated in your immune system to kill that which you have antibodies against, which if it is
self-tissue, you're stimulated in your immune system to kill your own tissue. Bethelene blue is not
an immune stimulator. It's typically thought of as an immune modulator, but just because something is
typically thought of as something safe, it doesn't mean that you won't react differently to it.
Everybody's a little bit different. Everybody has a different physiology and your body can act
differently towards things. So I'd always recommend that you test things. The only way is you can know
that your test is at least the most accurate you can be is to do things one at a time. So you're
going to add a supplement. Don't make any other drastic changes in your diet or your lifestyle or
your habits or anything while you're testing that supplement. So you can try it for a couple
days. Did it make you feel worse? No. Did it make you feel better? Well, I haven't figured that
what I'll get, but it's you're really testing. Does that make you feel worse? If by taking something,
it makes you feel worse that it's quite possible that it's stimulated in your immune system.
And that's not a good thing. Now, the issue that I see with people with chronic life many times,
they've been told incorrect things like, oh, you're just having a herx reaction. That's actually good.
You're having a lot of die-off of the Lyman co-infections. And that's most the time when that is
happening. That's not what's taking place. That if they do have antibodies in self-tissue and they're
taking some protocol that's making symptoms worse, more often than not. It's actually stimulated
in their immune system and they're destroying self-tissue. So they're making their immune,
they're making their autoimmune disease worse. They're actually worsening their condition.
Many things are blamed on symptoms. They're playing out of herx reaction. And that's just not true.
Okay. Question from the chat.
Histonines feed my cancer. Most of my protein has been plant-based and are high in histonines.
Meat is an option, but I've read a number of times that animal protein can feed cancer. What do you
recommend? Well, it's true. Amino acids can feed cancer. The most common amino acid that is a cancer
feeder, you could say, glutamine. That's the thing that you need to stay away from number one.
The most common source of fuel for any cancer is going to be glucose, though. By far,
it's going to be glucose. So stay on a diet that's relatively low in glucose. What are you eating?
Well, you're eating vegetables. Well, a lot of vegetables will break down into glucose ultimately.
Will protein break down into glucose? No. Protein is going to break down into amino acids.
But can my cancer change its fuel source and feed off amino acids? Yes. But by far in general,
you're going to have a cancer that's going to be more glucose dependent. So stay on a low glucose
diet is going to mean that you're going to be eating more animal proteins. So again,
I'm in the camp that I think testing and retesting to see where the fuel source is,
is the best way to go. Second best way to go would be to do experimentation with yourself as my
cancer stayed at bay with my diet, then maybe stay on that diet. If my cancer stayed at bay with my
diet for a period of time, and now my cancer is starting to grow, then it's time to change things
up and to change your diet. So if I've been eating like a type of ketogenic diet or ketogenic
like what I've stayed really low on sugar and I'm eating a lot more animal proteins,
and then my cancer starts to grow again. Maybe the fuel source has changed and you need to switch
to maybe a raw more vegetarian type diet for a period of time. So you have to be able to
to make changes. Cancer is trying to find a fuel source at all times you have to be willing to make
changes. Yes, if histamines are a feeder of your diet, you have to be careful of histamines,
but the truth is if you look up a histamine diet online, pretty much everything contains histamine.
So you would not be able to eat really anything. So the idea is not to try to eliminate histamines,
which is just pretty much an impossibility. It's trying to reduce main histamine load. So even okay,
nuts contain histamines, you're not eating any nuts. Well, maybe you won't eat a bowl full of nuts,
but you could still put some nuts on your salad. So it's a matter of just having balance,
you're not getting these histamine spikes. The other thing you do is the histamines in your diet,
obviously are going in your stomach, going in your intestines, and they're broken down by an enzyme
called DAO enzyme. If you add that enzyme to your dietary protocol,
meaning you take the capsule of DAO, when you eat food, when you eat a meal,
you will help break down those histamines, and then you won't have that issue with histamines.
Histamines can also be an issue, can get more complicated. Histamines can also be an issue,
if the person has a lot of leak, he got issues and a lot of inflammation from something totally
other than histamine. Let's say they have a undiagnosed client sensitivity, so they have antibodies
to gluten. They're still eating gluten on their diet. It's causing this inflammation of the gut,
so you're causing this inflammatory reaction that got increased production of histamine,
and then you're absorbing those, and that's causing systemic inflammation, and that's the problem.
So looking for sources of systemic inflammation is the next step to go as well.
I recommend that's why with all of our cancer patients, we give them access to our autoimmune course.
Why? I don't have autoimmune disease. Well, having a comorbidity of an autoimmune disorder
with cancer can be a co-feeder of the cancer, a co-inhibitor of a person being able to get rid of
the cancer, because they're dealing with these battles at multiple fronts. So if you can defeat
the battles at the different fronts, decreasing the inflammation at different areas, your immune system
is going to be calmed down enough to be able to concentrate on killing the cancer.
Then with diet, again, with cancer, you do have to get enough protein in your diet in order to make
the T cells and natural killer cells that are so necessary. Those are the some type of lymphocytes
that are really going to be cancer killers, and they are completely dependent on protein intakes.
You have to be able to eat it up protein in order to get that. So it's a little tricky to maneuver,
but you have to work through those circumstances. What influence to think copper deficiency has on
people? Have people supplemented it even though food or pill form? How much? How would you take?
Well, I do there is a phenomenon of some group of people that have copper deficiency, but by far,
by far, it is outweighed by people who have copper toxicity. So copper deficiency exists,
but copper toxicity is by far more common. So I'm not a big fan of taking an exogenous copper and
let you test your zinc copper ratio and see what your levels are. So you don't, you know,
one of the worst things with cancer is the people have a copper toxicity, especially in certain types
of cancer, like prostate cancer and several other types of cancer. It's very common to have
copper toxicity as a deficiency. I don't let any of my cancer patients take exogenous copper.
Copper is going to be a feeder of growth and all the years of taking care of cancer patients that
never had a copper deficient patient. So I know what exists. I know it ties to
adrenal issues and some other issues, but you need to get a blood test and get tested. So I am not a
fan of using exogenous copper, used that is copper in supplements. You'll see in our
multimeterals and things only choose those that do not have copper. I don't, that's one of the reasons
why I don't like multiple vitamins for my cancer patients, because they almost always have copper,
they almost always have methylated B vitamins, which is another no-no for cancer,
and several other no-nos for cancer, too. So to answer your question, what would you do with
copper deficiency? Well, first of all, you have to get it properly diagnosed. If you have it properly
diagnosed and you do truly have a copper deficiency based upon the copper zinc ratio,
then you could supplement with copper. That's not something I've ever had to deal with.
While treating breast cancer with nightly rife programs, I tested positive for some
mycotoxins and I'm also detoxifying parasites, specifically liver flukes and others I am sure.
I've been running separate rife programs for molds and parasites. Do you have any specific ones
that you would recommend and how often? Well, I wouldn't run any, I wouldn't spend time
running any programs for molds. So when you're tested for mycotoxins, understand that is a
toxin that a mold produces, and then you have consumed it or breathed it in, and now that is
an inner toxin. That's not a living organism. So the programs on the rife for molds and fungus,
you really don't need to run unless you think you have an acute mold,
toxin, mold poisoning, living organism, typically you're going to have one of the issues.
So an acute fungal infection typically is going to be lung issues, breathing issues, then you
could run molds and fungus programs out of the rife. But if you're going off, well, I don't have
that. I'm doing it because I have a positive mycotoxin test. That's not a mold and fungus.
That is a toxin that a mold produces that you consume somehow. So there really is a
derived program to get rid of mycotoxins, except doing the foot bath programs with detox and supporting
detoxification. As far as the parasite programs, yeah, if you know the specific parasite that you have,
then you can run that specific parasite program. I don't know what the specific parasite I have is.
We'll run the all-bugs kill program. That's my favorite. The rife is the all-bugs kill. There's
an overnight all-bugs kill if you want to do that or stay type all-bugs kill program. And if you
notice that there's stuff coming out of you when you're running a program, then stay running that
program. So, you know, frequencies are a little bit cool too, then just because we know that this
frequency is tied to this parasite, it can function. It can kill other parasites too. So, run whatever
works for you. Our mitochondria-enhancine supplements, such as Euro-ethnicated a safe for use during
cancer. The standard answer, a lot of functional medicine doctors out there. Okay, so I'm going to
say this to not be offensive. We have a lot of people that come to us that were put on supplements
that I don't, I personally wouldn't recommend for somebody with cancer. And here's the reason.
So, a cancer is rapidly replicated by definition. So, something got inside of a cell and damaged
the nucleus, many times it's an oxidative agent. Many times it's some sort of toxin, a poison can be
a biotoxin, but it damaged the nucleus. And now that cell is rapidly replicated, cells that are
also damaged in rapid replication. By that definition, they are not replicating super-healthy cells.
So, the mitochondria of these new rapidly replicated cells is not producing the right type of
anti-oxidants in the right quantity of antioxidants to keep that cell healthy. So, they're not producing
a lot of glutthione, they're not producing a lot of superoxide, disputation, catalyst. That makes a
cancer cell closer to legal dose of oxidative stress building up within the cell. And we take advantage
of that. So, knowing that a cancer cell is less healthy than a healthy cell because it has a
greater amount of oxidative stress building up within the cell because the mitochondria are less healthy.
We can take advantage of that and medicine takes advantage of that. That's what chemotherapy does,
chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent. And in doing so, it tips over cancer cells faster than it will
tip over a healthy cell that's got a healthy mitochondria that is producing a lot of antioxidants.
So, when we go and take exogenous antioxidants, we need supplements of antioxidants. We take
supplements that are going to support mitochondrial function. We take glutathione, we take superoxide,
disputation, catalysts, and other antioxidants that we are basically helping cancer cells stay alive.
So, I don't think that's a good idea. Most natural cancer treatments, okay.
Standards of care cancer treatments, chemotherapy are oxidizing agents. They're trying to tip over
cells that are already in oxidative stress. Most alternative cancer therapies,
Prona cell and IV, or IV vitamin C and dematine and hoxy and things like that are also oxidative.
So, they're tipping over those cells in a maybe less damaging way to healthy cells. And that's the argument
for alternative care. But if you are also taking a bunch of antioxidants because you know, they're good
for you, my paragraphs, what we have, these, or whatever, that's just not the right thing to do.
So, I'm just totally against that. So, I take everybody, you know, come to me, I'm going to take you off
all your antioxidants. So, let's testing you, that tests good for you, but it's a few people that do. So,
I don't think you should be a mitochondrial enhancement supplement. That's my opinion.
My grandson, two and a half years old, keeps getting sick, first draft, then two weeks later,
another infection, and bad cough, then two weeks later, now fever again, he had two rounds of
antibiotics. What can he do? Okay, so, the thing is, is that when our children get ill,
we live in a culture where we tend to run them to the doctor and get it antibiotic. Well,
sometimes when you got a nasty, strapped infection, you should get it antibiotic. You don't want it
to bleed to something worse, like pandas or something. But most of the time, if you let that child
cycle through that infection, so, when you first get an infection, you have this immediate response,
your immediate immediate response, that's called a TH1 response with all these different types of
immediate immune cytokine releases and chemokine releases that are attacking the infection. So,
think of it as that this infection, these bad guys that entered the body, and this immediate
response is the police force that's going out to try to kill this infection. Well, if it's a pretty
nasty infection, the police force can't kill it, and after a few days, the police force gets
called back, and they said the FBI, and the FBI get in there, that's your B cell or TH2 response,
to go in there and find the enemies and take them with fluorescent tape, so that now the police
can see them and find them easier. That's called a TH1 TH2 full immune response, which is hindered if
we run off and get antibiotics, or, first, my kids got a fever, so I'm going to take Tylenol,
then we're not letting them cycle through this whole TH1, TH2 response, and only when you go
through that TH2 B cell response, will you create antibodies against that infection? Now, the benefit
of creating antibodies against an infection is that after the infection is over, you still have
circulated antibodies against that infection. That's what you say, oh, Johnny's got such a strong
immune system, he doesn't get sick. Well, why doesn't Johnny get sick? He's still exposed to
everything that Billy's exposed to, but Billy keeps getting sick. Well, Johnny's mom let him cycle
through that whole infectious process at least a few times, so now he's got circulated antibodies
against that strap, so when he's exposed to the same amount of strap that Billy's exposed to,
Billy doesn't have circulated antibodies, he gets sick. Johnny doesn't get really sick, maybe he
doesn't feel great for a day or so, but the antibodies take the strap, then the TH1 police force
get in there and kill the strap. That's what's called habited in a healthy immune system, so the
definition of a healthy immune system means that I am more circulated antibodies against more pathogens
than somebody else does, so I have a healthier immune system than somebody else because I have more
circulated antibodies against more pathogens. That's what you want to have. That's the only way that
you can have that is if you allow yourself to get sick and you nurse yourself through that sickness and
to have some chicken soup and take some supplements and build up your immune system and strengthen
your immune system so that you do fire a whole B cell response and develop antibodies for that.
But I know we live in the most generation, we've lived in a culture where you know mom's not home,
we can't stay home, we got to run to the doctor, get it antibiotic otherwise they won't let it back
into take care or school or whatever and that's not necessarily good and so we need to develop
that immune system. Other things help build up for child immune system too, where they breastfed,
what's the child's diet like? Are they eating a lot of different foods so they have a good
healthy probiotic sources to help build their microbiota? Are they
supporting their immune system through different nutrition? Are they eating dyes in food colorings
or are they eating in a inflammatory diet? Are they eating things that they have antibodies against?
Are they eating glue to the dairy and things that they might have antibodies and that are causing
inflammation and they're fighting this battle at both ends and now they got this inflammatory
process right off this infection so you want to take a big picture, approach that and dig into this
whether they're five years old or whether you're 25 years old. I had horrible positive
breast cancer seven years ago, my body tolerated to moxin for four years besides
dim, what would be the next best supplement to prevent metastatic disease? Well your natural
aroma taste inhibitors are going to be dim, so for a fame and you can go to our website
countersclinic.com and just search natural aroma taste or search, search aroma taste
and that's I have a whole list of it in an article on natural aroma taste inhibitors and things
that I would suggest, so I'll let you do that because we're being inundated with questions,
but dimox if it is an aroma taste, it hymics blocking all estrogens, you tolerated it well and
it's helped a lot, but when you get to a point I know they want people to take it for 10 years,
sometimes they'll tell people they're going to take it to rest of your life and it can be intolerable,
it does block all your estrogens, not just your bad estrogens, so looking for a natural aroma taste
inhibitor might be a wise choice, also running a Dutch test would be what we talked about earlier in
the show would be a wise choice too, because that's going to give you a picture where your horrible
Zarat and how much you really need to hit, how hard you need to hit, trying to do natural aroma taste
inhibitors. Is this recorded? I was late. Yes, it's recorded and you can find all the recordings at
the our website holistichealthower.com, that's where you could ask questions
pre-show as well, that's where you'll see all our other shows as well and they're nicely indexed
so that you can find answers to questions. Also, I'd recommend if you don't get your question
answered on the show to go to our website like iJustExplainCuttersClinic.com,
C-O-N-N-E-R-S-Clinic.com, in search, because I've moved about 1200 blog posts and most of them have
videos explaining things in detail at nausea to you to help with the the question you might have.
Why not methylated B vitamins for cancer? Okay, so methyl groups are essential
for life. We need methyl groups, so a methyl group is a carbon with three hydrogens and it can
bind to, you could use it to bind to different nutrients to get them exogenously. You also get methyl groups
through your foods, so most people that are eating good diets are getting plenty of methyl groups.
But taking exogenous methyl groups, taking exogenous methyl groups and B vitamins,
you're taking methyl cabolamine, which is methyl B12 for methyl tetrahedral folate, which is a
methyl folate. Now, most natural doctors will say that's the best type of folate, that's the best
type of B12. Well, maybe, maybe not. Well, it's certainly maybe not if you have cancer. The reason
is that one of the major things that methyl groups do is they silence genes, so they turn off genes,
which you need to have genes turned off at different times. However, one of your greatest
way to kill cancer, if you have cancer, is through a pathway called your intrinsic meaning inside
the cell, capsaic pathway or intrinsic apoptotic pathway. So the intrinsic apoptotic pathway is
stimulated by when a cancer cell is going through rapid replication, it stimulates what are called
your tumor suppressor genes. Everybody has them. You have lots of different tumor suppressor gene
families. The bronca gene is probably the most well-known by lay people. So the bronca genes are a
tumor suppressor gene that turns out with breast cancer and can help kill the breast cancer, so you'd
never know you even have breast cancer because it's dead before it gets to a size if you ever
discovered that. Now, if you take a bunch of methyl groups, you can turn those genes off,
so you can hinder your body's ability to kill cancer. So my rule is, if you have cancer, you're not
taking methyl groups, take other forms of B12 and other forms of folate. I have uterine cancer since
2018, but had no surgery, etc. I've been vegan since 2010. It's been getting bigger. So would you
go would going raw vegan work or do you recommend to rife machine? So first of all, yes, I'd recommend
to rife machine with anybody that has cancer, absolutely contact our office. But if you've been
vegan since 2010 and your cancer is getting bigger, it's time to change your diet. Okay, vegan is not
the thing you should be doing. So remember, cancer, if you were listening before, cancer is always
trying to fight a fuel source. So if what you're doing right now, diet terribly, the cancer is growing
then you need to change things up. So I'd have to get more data on what you're
classified as vegan. Certainly, like I said, cancer in order for you to make kill cancer cells by
your immune system, the subtype of the sites you are completely dependent on your protein intake. So
I would change up your diet, get a rife machine, probably multiple of the things as well.
What do you think about intravenous vitamin C and baking soda intravenously? We found a clinic in
Arizona. Does that does that for cancer? intravenous vitamin C, yes, baking soda intravenous. I don't
know about that. No, you have to see, understand, you have a buffering system in your body. You can't,
you know, people like, oh, I just need to alkalize myself. I just need to alkalize myself. I just need to
get out, you know, but yeah, no, it doesn't work that way. If your blood varies very much off of
I think the pH of 7.345 or something like that for blood, you'll die. So your body will
buffer it. So if you could somehow alkalize your blood, your body wouldn't have to be working very
hard to acidify it to balance out the pH, or you'll just die. So no, vitamin C IV, yes, that could be
a very good benefit for cancer. You could do intravenous vitamin C, you know, you don't have to
go away to a clinic. Every large city has IV centers that you could do vitamin C IV locally. Plus,
you need to do that on a very regular basis once or twice a week or to be effective. So
give in your views about antioxidants. What do you think about corsetin, which has
antioxidant qualities, but is also directly cytotoxic, rheumatacitivity, detoxified, it's a flavonoid.
So yeah, I'm talking about what you're talking about, not taking antioxidant, you're talking about
not taking these strongly antioxidants, alpha-lopeic acid, glutathioneal, edicidal cystine,
SOD, catalyzed. Those are the things that you're not going to be on. So corsetin, yes, you can
be on corsetin, that's just fine. It has many other, so there's a lot of different nutrients
have to be oxidant. Benefits, in fact, I wrote an article and it's in our blog posts called
Harnessine Oxidative Stress to Kill Cancer. There are certain things like you think, okay, vitamin C
is an antioxidant. Why are you saying you should do it or eat a vitamin C? Well, vitamin C
at a higher dosage actually has oxidative stress qualities, not antioxidant. Vitamin E at a higher
dosage is an oxidative. A selenium at high dose is oxidative. Melatotin at high dose, that's why you
do 60, 80, 120, 200 milligrams of melatonin for a cancer patient. Well, what does that make them
sleep? No, it's an oxidative stress treatment. So that's what's a lot of different nutrients. Higher
dose, they have more oxidative stress qualities. In large adrenal gland remedies, if you have it in
large adrenal gland, you want to find out why. So that is not obviously normal. So if
was it diagnosed through an ultrasound, as being one of them was larger than the other, you'd want
to figure out why. Is there a tumor? Is there a tumor? You'd want to figure out why. Normally,
you don't have an enlarged adrenal gland. A person can be very normal to have an enlarged heart
because that person was an athlete or something as a youth. And you can have issues with that.
But in a large adrenal gland, you'd want to do some more investigation. Listen to a cancer
webinar last night, advocated hydrogen water. Do you have opinions of hydrogen water better to drink
or breathe hydrogen air? So yeah, there are some, there's some data out there about hydrogen water
and cancer. Hydrogen water and just general health. That is very intriguing. So I think I don't see
anything wrong with using hydrogen water. We did, it was about seven, eight years ago, we cut it in
a deep dive and that first came out. And the only thing I had against it is that with our patients,
we haven't been doing a lot of things already. And one of our philosophical things is trying
to have the person spending their whole day on different therapies. If you have a hydrogen water
machine, I think that's a great thing to use. Echo water. Yeah, echo water was actually the machine
that we researched. I think it's a good, good tool. Is resveratrol and co-Q10 okay since they are
antioxidants? Yes. So they have more anti-inflammatory properties than antioxidants. So yes, those
are applied to use with cancer. Yes. Okay. Blog kind of earlier kind of blew up there for a second
but I do have a couple of questions I got to answer here that people sent it beforehand. A cause
is a benign tumors similar to the causes of cancerous tumors, toxic, overload, etc. If you have
a benign tumor, does that tell us something about our health that needs to change? Well, yeah, whenever
you have anything wrong like a benign tumor or a cancerous tumor or any type of side or symptom
is a side or symptom that's something may need to change. I say it may need to change because it
could have been something that you were exposed to years ago that you don't have that exposure,
you already changed that. For instance, maybe you were living in a moldy house when you were a kid,
you picked up a lot of mycotoxin and that has caused now damage and maybe even caused a tumor,
but if you did a mycotoxin test today, your body had cleared it out that was maybe 20 years ago
and you inadvertently cleared it out because your body's constantly trying to detoxify. But it did
lead lasting damage. So it might not be something that you need current change to, but maybe you need
the current change to help decrease the growth of that tumor. So there's a lot of none of cancerous
tumors like mypomas. Mypomas can have congenital ties to them too, eating their genetic predisposition
to mypomas. A lot of non-cancerous tumors are very idiopathic, but they don't know what causes them.
Where the hypothesis is that it's the same as cancer, it can be toxin, etc., that can lead to that,
but there can be genetic pieces to that too. But yeah, like anything, you do want to investigate
current exposure to different things. You do want to investigate toxic levels and you do want to
support detoxification pathways, etc., especially depending on where the bite tumor is if you have
a bite tumor in your head. That's a space occupied lesion where you have only so much space
so that can cause just as much problem as a malignant tumor in the brain too.
Hello, I live in Elma, Kirkki, New Mexico. In short, many members of my family suffer from
chronic and debilitated conditions. Can you recommend functional medicine or holistic practitioners
in my area? I can't, I mean, you can consult with me everything we do in our clinic is distant. We
have patients from in Australia and New Zealand and I'll literally, in Europe all over the world,
and so you can make an appointment with us. If you do want to go to codersclinic.com and you can
see that you can schedule now would make a case review with me. If you don't want to do that,
at least get out our courses, our courses are only about 50 bucks right now.
And for something like this, I join the autoimmune course. You can start digging in and
diving into some videos and different things and learn that, you know, there's something that
you might be exposed to. Whenever you have this multiple family members have an issue, you have to
look at familial ties, not so much genetic, but familial ties. Are we all exposed to moldy
house? Are we all exposed to toxic water? Are we all living in an area where there's, you know,
a different types of airborne fungi? You know, are there heavy metals in, you know,
or vicinity, you know, is an EMF issue? There's all sorts of different things that as a group,
we're all exposed to that same thing. So, yeah, so you can, you can somebody did say,
so Neil Pie has a clinic in Albuquerque, so you can find somebody locally too.
All right. Well, thanks for another episode of holistic health. I remember you could go to
holisticelthower.com where you're going to see these presentations. Again, there will be indexed.
This one will be up in a couple days, give it a few days time. But you can see all our past episodes.
Also, if you have questions that aren't answered, here go to codersclinic.com. Search in the search bar.
We have, you know, a nice search engine on there that you can search for different topics.
And we have, you know, over a thousand blog posts with videos. Also, check out our video channel
and look at our courses. I think you'll find them helpful. All right. Everybody have a
blessed day and I'll see you next week. Bye-bye.